I don't have much of a
script for this video.
A few weeks ago,
I saw a clip of a Japanese inventor
who's been running his own
“Micro Hovercraft Laboratory” for years.
So I asked my local producer in Japan
to get in touch and ask
while I'm in the country,
can I please meet the inventor?
Can I see the hovercraft
and maybe have a go flying it?
So now we've taken a bullet train to
Tsubame City, two hours north of Tokyo,
and I'm going to meet Hideyasu Ito
at the local sports center.
Now, I do have a little bit of experience
with hovercraft...
but this is one person's
home-made vehicle, so...
I'm going to be careful
not to break it.
Hello.
Could you demonstrate?
Could you show me around? Thank you.
How do you steer?
- This button...
...turn.
Turn.
- Okay.
- Both switch...
Straight.
Okay?
- Okay.
And this...
...clockwise, there.
Up and down.
About 1700.
- One seven zero zero.
Okay.
Is that okay?
Hang on...
That is incredible.
Thank you so much.
Arigato gozaimasu!